when Adam Lanza shot his way into Sandy
Hook elementary school he was carrying
three weapons and hundreds of rounds of
ammunition acting alone in just 11
minutes
he used an assault rifle to murder 20
children and six members of staff before
killing himself he was 20 years old and
a former pupil at the school as a
community grieved an America reeled the
question was why but now after a
year-long investigation Connecticut
officials say they may never be able to
answer as they combed through Lanza's
home investigators did find signs of a
disturbed man evidence of target
practice violent computer games in
literature an empty gun cupboard the
rifle he used to kill his mother before
he went to the school computer searches
revealed an obsession with mass murder
particularly the Columbine school
shooting he had made a spreadsheet
listing prerequisites for mass murder
there was a video dramatization of
children being shot and a game called
school shooting despite all of this and
significant mental health issues
investigators said he wasn't aggressive
or threatening before this attack there
were simply no reasonable explanation or
excuse they said for what he did
in the aftermath President Obama tried
and failed to tighten gun laws his
supporters may hope this new report
reignites that debate but Sandy Hook is
gone now and many of the families are
still grieving and they still want
answers Hannah tars Peter Sky News
Newtown Connecticut